dude so this actually is really
interesting right let's get in trouble
let's let's uh let's let's jump right in
and get in trouble where's this
this tweet here we go oh yeah so i have
this tweet from jama are you familiar
with jama
i am not so jama network is
news guard certified so newsguard says
that
it is a a website for 13 medical
journals published by the american
medical association
they consider it to be overwhelmingly
credible with a 92.5 out of 100 and they
say
racial ethnic variation in nasal gene
expression of transmembrane
sarin protease 2 the the the tweet they
put out
says that given the given the essential
role of tmpr
ss2 in sars cova 2 entry higher nasal
expression
of tmprss2 may contribute to the higher
burden of covid19
among black individuals the first reply
race is not genetic do better well what
do you mean do better it's a scientific
study how do you
do better science well i mean if you
there was a study that's done where you
get individuals and they give you their
self-identified
race and then they look at their genes
and they look at how they cluster based
on self-identified race
interesting and they all cluster
basically in the exact same groups that
you would think so
there's it's a very low resolution uh
depiction of what these are general
racial categories you know like white
african-american
it's a super low resolution if you turn
up the sensitivity high enough you can
see these things kind of come out in
sort of a
clustered fashion genetically um
and they're they do give some useful
information so i don't think we should
be using these
the generic racial categories there's
much more easily
uh finer scale variation that you can
pick up that might have
uh relevance in the medical field like
only certain
uh populations of black individuals have
sickle cell anemia was like some
sub-saharan africa
populations have these but to say i mean
they're saying race is not genetic but
their idea of race is sort of this
socially constructed version but that's
not to say that human variation
isn't genetic i mean human variation is
by definition i mean
what do they mean by race in this in
this in this regard
that's not genetic well they would say
the categories that we
call these races were constructed by
white
western heterosexual i mean individually
definitions and and observations were
made
typically in science as we know it from
many white individuals
we also collaborate with other countries
i mean india and japan for instance
contribute
to a lot of scientific major scientific
breakthroughs and studies as to a lot of
other countries we don't just assume
that well they make the assumption that
white people have invented everything
well they would say that because there's
not like any single
criteria that defines one race from
another you can't boil it down to a
single tiny
one thing that makes somebody black or
one thing that makes somebody this
right therefore these categories don't
exist but that's ignoring a whole
type of thing called polythenic
categories where you can
belong to like a certain group that's
sort of a that's a cluster concept
it's it can have various characters that
co-vary
in a non-random way and you can you can
measure this statistically even though
um you know it's not you can't say that
these are super
distinct categories in any one way but
there are ways to cluster them
yeah yeah it is it is interesting
because people often reference say like
albino black people
and they'll say you can still tell that
they're you know
facial uh like you know the size of the
nose or whatever
you can make determinations on that that
they're albino or black or something
like that
but it actually is a really good point
to give credit where credit is due to
the left
when they say that that's a really good
example of the left's argument
that there are individuals who have
white skin
but have more similar face facial
formations to your typical black or
latino or asian person
and that person identify as one of those
not as white even though they have white
skin
and you end up with really weird things
from this argument though you end up
with white people with black hair saying
they're black and getting away with it
like this professor who's apparently
jewish and
so it is interesting though and i've
often thought about this
it how do you define what makes someone
black or not
right so we we kind of were critical of
the idea of the capital b
black the political black but there
there
there are challenges you know there
there are some people you might look at
and say
this person has white skin but they
identify as black
and they have black parents and there's
some you know pigmentation issue maybe
albinism and so they end up with whiter
skin
i guess i guess the issue i see is the
challenge in navigating
the space appropriately and properly to
make sure that we're we're being correct
we're being respectful uh correct first
and foremost but we do want to
make sure we're treating people like
human beings the challenge there
opens the door for a more extreme
version of there's no race
race is not genetic in any capacity and
stuff like that and then this just
basically
starts to expand from there and it's
almost like
science isn't perfect so they found a
hole or they found a thread
and they're pulling and unraveling the
whole sweater based off of one small
thread where they find an error you know
what i mean yeah it's like because you
can't identify one thing that makes
someone
definitively black or definitively asian
uh
and and they're again ignoring the the
statistical things that we do and we're
correlating different
you know single nucleotide polymorphisms
and populations i mean we can get down
to such fine scale
population differences if you look in
india you can actually look at
the way that the population is
structured based on the caste system
that they had
for long periods of time where you had
more likely to have
uh breeding within cast than between
them this creates certain genetic
structures between
between certain populations makes sense
that can be measured like that's what
we're talking about that's that's a much
more recent
effect but you can still say that those
are real it's not like
a person from this one cast is
completely different than this other
they're not like different species
yeah but you can still look at these
correlational differences between their
genetic structure you can say
you are more most likely from you know a
brahman cast or something right uh and
well i mean we this is something the
human population geneticists have no
problem talking about
with other geneticists but if you were
to say that this
corresponds to anything real to the
social justice well i got
i got my uh uh not me but members of my
family have gotten their you know
ancestry or whatever
and it comes back and it says here are
all the things you are
like you know how can they tell you that
if it wasn't really genetic or whatever
well maybe there's something to this
whole genetics thing yeah
yeah yeah yeah but i guess it's a it's
it's you know it's racist
bigoted i wonder what the what's your
let's do this let's take everything
we've talked about just now
fast forward 10 years
[Laughter]
assuming this keeps going what would you
what would you predict
everyone i would expect if it keeps
going at the same clip
i well i don't think i can so if it
keeps going to this clip i think it's
gonna
max out and there's either gonna be some
sort of revolution or
no one's gonna know up from down or left
from right because it's just to be
everything's been deconstructed i like
to imagine that everybody has to wear
a giant like cardboard box around their
body
that they like move around it's not not
it's like dragging on the ground too
and they have they speak through a
text-to-speech so that no one knows
anyone's gender or
race or whatever and in order to
communicate you type in the keyboard
like i am hungry and would like to get a
cheeseburger and it would expect i
am hungry would like to eat cheeseburger
that would be too colorblind though
because that's
that's racist oh that's a good point
yeah so then there would be you need to
take them to
their accounts you need to be you'd have
a checklist or something outside of like
no no
the the the asian people would have like
their
everyone's skin tone would be the color
of their box but you couldn't see
anything else
is it is it can you be gender blind is
that also bigoted
i think it probably is there's no answer
i'm gonna go with yes on this one okay
how about everybody's wearing a gray
jumpsuit they have shaved heads
and if you're a dude they malnourish you
to a certain degree
so everybody will be basically the same
height
and weight and they'll hold hands yeah i
don't think we could get to where we are
right now so
that's not too far-fetched honestly i
think
to be more realistic and you know put
the jokes aside i think the reality is a
right wing reaction
i think that the more psychotic this
stuff becomes
there's whether the left wants to admit
it or not people have
certain biological drives and they're
going to want these things
like eating food you know like we all
crave
food or we die and you can't just act
like these things don't exist
and people want to have families it's
interesting i was looking at a study a
while ago
and it was um what do you think most
people value
and what do you value the most and most
people said
other people want to be famous they said
what do you value family
everybody said they valued family but
everyone else valued fame
it's a really interesting phenomena if
that's the case
then you have people most people just
want to have a family
well if you say you want to disrupt the
nuclear family like black lives matter
does
eventually you're going to have regular
people saying i want a family
they're going to look to their left and
they're going to see people saying break
the family apart they're going to look
to their right and they're going to be
they're going to see people with the
smiling family in a picket fence and
they're going to be like i'll take that
what they don't realize is they're
looking at you know fascists
and they're going to say i want this one
thing and i bring that up
almost as a bit of a self-criticism
because here we are you know you
mentioned earlier you were not for
school choice before but you are now
because of the manifestation of this
weird politics and i mentioned that i
wasn't
you know i don't say i was against gun
rights or anything like that but i
definitely leaned more towards you know
what common sense gun control and i
didn't want to own any guns
now i own a bunch and i'm like nah get
out of here don't take my guns you know
what i mean
yeah so we've we've been pushed to that
side because the left is
scarier and goes against our own drives
for for me
safety and security and i think it's
actually similar for you in terms of
school choice
yeah i've stayed i've changed on minor
policy type things but i'd say
since i was 20 i don't think my my
fundamental
politics hasn't really changed much but
relative to where the center is given
that the left is sort of gone out right
super far now i'm just considered
centrist or even maybe
center right by some people i would i
would i would say by uh you know
standard
american this this generation my
policies my politics are very liberal
at least where liberal used to be but
now liberal today is blindly following
far left progressive insanity and so
they call me conservative
and i'm like i have very few
conservative positions and there are a
lot of union democrats that have
historically been pro-2a
so that's not even necessarily their
blue states that are very much
pro-second amendment
you know vermont for instance bernie
sanders used to have a good position on
on gun control saying it was an
urban versus a rural issue and i was
like that's a brilliant point that's why
i liked him back in the day
now he's kind of sold out but i it's
it's
the the right is not really moving all
that much
and they're opening up their tent to
liberals who still believe in their
same liberal positions but the far left
and whatever liberal is supposed to mean
today
doesn't represent in my opinion the
average american
they they like to claim most amer this
america is a progressive country
and it's a lie they just do they just do
clever word play
my favorite is the green new deal here's
what they do this is how polls work you
probably know
would you support the government
investing into research for green
green technologies to help reduce carbon
emissions well yes they would absolutely
you are for the green new deal check
then they come out and they say 87 were
in favor of green new deal
policies you see they reframe the answer
different from the question of course
they'll say here's our full
you know questionnaire and here's what
we asked but nobody goes in there
some people do but then the headline is
87 support the green new deal why
it's the it's the bias people see polls
and they assume if most people like it
they'll just say sure i'm for it too
because they want to fit in
that's where we're at thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time